après la formidable réussite de port
marly l'année dernière la formidable
mobilisation depuis les succès se sont
enchaînés
nous avons bien sûr gagner les
municipales mais aussi les
départementales et régionales est le
premier parti de france doit être
incarné par un mouvement jeunes qu'ils
soient forts qu'ils soient autonomes
c'est ce que j'ai voulu au moment de mon
élection à la présidence de notre de
notre mouvement et maintenant c'est
pleins feux sur le parc floral les 4 et
5 septembre avec un grand rassemblement
de jeunesse et cette jeunesse elle doit
s'incarner les doit s'incarner par un
mouvement autonome autonome sur le plan
financier mais surtout autonome sur les
idées autonome sur sa représentation sur
son incarnation que nous avons voulu
avec le présent christian jacob avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe nationale d une
républicain renouvelé cette rentrée des
républicains sous le signe de la
jeunesse le 4 et 5 septembre
nous comptons sur vous pour faire de
cette rentrée politique des républicains
une véritable réussite
alors vous avez jusqu'au 31 juillet pour
vous inscrire et nous rejoindre pour ce
week-end de fête
ça n'est pas à nous ça n'est pas un
autre génération incarnée un mouvement
de jeunesse c'est aux jeunes de le faire
d'être capable de porter les idées les
projets et d'être très présent dans
l'élection présidentielle donc on a
besoin d'une formidable mobilisation
après ses résultats électoraux et
surtout d'être partie prenante dans la
campagne des présidentielles
on doit porter les idées des jeunes les
républicains aujourd'hui c'est la
jeunesse et c'est ce que nous devons
réussir à partir du grand rassemblement
du parc floral alors les 4 et 5
septembre on compte sur vous pour que
vous veniez très nombreux à la rentrée
des jeunes républicains pour marquer la
reconquête de la droite l'année
prochaine on compte sur vous on compte
sur vous dans toutes les fédérations de
france pour nous rejoindre
alors rendez vous le 4 et 5 septembre